hi everybody its Kevin here and I'm here
with John from for lights too so that he
can show us defenders of time which has
already been on our e3 stage show but
the games come a long way since then is
what I hear anyway John is that what do
you been up to between then and now
we've been busy on the polish of the
game there's there's a lot to that goes
in making to making a game to get it
past the alpha stage that we were in
we've put in more Maps we've made
matchmaking a real thing we've put in
friends lists we've put in ranking
systems we've put in a news page we've
done a lot with the game so the first
thing that we're doing here is we are
looking at the lines that we've got that
are coming from each of the source areas
so you can see that there are a couple
of source areas up here there's another
one down here and we've get developers
over in in Vegas who are playing with us
so they they know what I'm about to do
but you can see on the ground down here
there are actually lines and these lines
will change so I can turn them on and
off and they'll change dynamically with
where the creeps are allowed to go so if
I start to build something here it'll
actually change that and if I block it
off entirely they'll go around so
there's some some maze work here that
you're doing to force them into longer
paths for example yes way you could do
this when they are our main engineer
comes in and it's a Monday morning and I
guess I just got frustrated I I was just
really frustrated with camera because
the main unity camera pivots around a
central point and he had spent all
weekend he comes in on Monday and he
gave us this wonderful camera that'll
really do anything that we want it to do
it'll zoom out far we can get really in
close to see the towers and the action
happening and it was really a surprise
and we're very proud of it because it's
such a nice feature so I've activated
the air pads here because
kind of hair guys coming at it just
turns on the markers for them so they
don't get in the way when I don't need
them hey guys don't don't delete those
so we also have voice chat in this when
I hold town II I can actually talk to
them and tell them what I need them to
do and they can tell me what they need
me to do in addition to our other
drawing tools and our pinging ability so
when I when I hit ping you can actually
see the little arrow there right totally
and you did a little what looked like a
little tellest raishin there a second
ago what was that all about
oh yeah when you hit when you hold down
shift in this game you can draw and it's
it's so that we can say hey look I need
you to build this complex maze shape
over here and I need you to do this this
game is really a multiplayer game it's
not about the story that we were trying
to tell it's about the battle that we're
having hey Kurt spend your money so
we've got a hundred percent sell it's
better to spend your money in this game
than to hang on with it if you make a
mistake like I got oh this towers wrong
I can sell it but then I go oh yeah no
actually that was right because they're
sending off masked units at us and I can
build it right back up the enemy's got a
commander and the commander is actually
on the same map as we are he's actually
looking at our map right now and he's
going how can I hurt them he's saying
okay they've got green here and I see a
lot of brown which is kind of neutral
and I see a little bit of stealth
detection over here and I see a little
bit of anti-armor so what are they weak
against so obviously he's decided that
well we're really strong against ground
so he's sending air of course so right
now I'm gonna go and go ahead and delete
all this anti ground stuff and improve
our anti-air zone
so another one of the really fun
features that we were proud of is called
rapid cell if I hold down our boom there
they all go yeah they just disappear
and if it's an upgraded tower it will
only sell to basic so it doesn't destroy
my maze when you play this game you're
playing on a team you're playing on a
team as a team and I know that sounds
really obvious but in a lot of games
we've played you're playing alone on a
team you're you're fighting a war alone
you just happen to have people who are
fighting the same war on the same side
as you in this game if you lose your
whole team loses and if you win your
whole team wins there's no MVP so money
is shared across everybody evenly it's
distributed evenly it's just in this
case so you can see up here I Robot he
doesn't have any money and he doesn't
have any way for me to give him money
but that's because he's a commander he's
spending his time analyzing the
situation these other guys though they
have the ability to sell the towers that
I've placed they can upgrade the towers
that I've built it's all in service of
the team instead of oneself if we lose
all of our scores we'll take a hit in
the ranking system now if I've lost if
I've personally lost a bunch of games in
a row my school will take more of a hit
than theirs will the other thing is we
don't have any part of war we wanted
players to be able to take a look at
what the other teams are doing and how
the other teams are doing it and we
wanted the commanders to be able to see
what was going on so if you hope press
tab it'll go it'll fast move to the
other team so right now
they've built up a really strong cluster
over here but as you guys can probably
see these little airlines they got going
they don't really pass through that zone
and they've got some green here
which really isn't gonna do much against
they're probably our best Arizona on
this map is right here they've got one
really strong tower right there but
otherwise they're kind of weak I don't
see much much white in here if any white
no I don't see any white at all which is
probably why our commander is sending
stealth so the only thing that can hurt
their stealth right now is are these
green towers which mean discriminately
hurt things but so are our commanders
doing the same thing right now he's
analyzing the other team and attacking
so tell me more about what the commander
is is up to during this time because
we're seeing it from your perspective
but what is the what is the role of a
commander right when I think of
something that has like a commander and
grunts a multiplayer for example I think
of things like natural selection and and
savage and things like that what is how
do they how does that role work here so
the commander affects things in an
oblique way so he can research better
offensive enemies or he can research
better defensive towers or he can he can
actually go and take this you see these
blue tower over here he can say oh well
I want to get to the top level blue
tower I want to be able to just freeze
everything in place all the time and he
can pretty much skip every other upgrade
if he wants to now his teammates would
probably kill him for that but he could
if he wanted to so that's kind of
interesting to me actually because to me
that that that says hey we've taken
we've made somebody else take care of
the really micromanaging things like
exactly what upgrade paths you're going
to take or clicking on every single
tower to upgrade every single tower
you know individually and things like
that you've basically given that off to
one person to do those things that's
only true when poor players are playing
when less than four players are playing
player number one is both a builder and
a commander which can get overwhelming
at times if you're not a really good
player we generally try to select the
best
player on a team to be a commander
because they really know what they're
there about we are all set to go for
November 4th the game's gonna be $20 if
you buy the game and your friends Tim
doesn't own the game you actually say
hey Tim download the game make it
account make a free account and then
once Tim's in the game he can play
single-player for free and I can
actually invite Tim and say hey Tim come
join my game that now he can actually
play the full game as long as we're
playing together only one player online
can do that if it's just one online
player you can invite them if you have a
second friend
one person's gonna need to buy a copy
but if it's on a land like you say you
having a birthday party or a pizza party
or you're at the office it only one
person needs to own the game for a full
four on four or eight person match and
after that what are your post release
plans for defenders of time in three or
four months we're gonna release an
expansion pack and the expansion pack
will be $5 and then we're going to do it
again and when that second expansion
pack comes out it'll also be $5 but the
first expansion pack will be free so
that anybody who gets into our game is
always either current or one expansion
pack behind you John thanks for stopping
by and we'll have you back soon I've no
doubt thank you for having us I really
appreciate it thanks for listening guys